welcome to that we spoiler show I'm your
host definition and with the MC you
pretty much just finishing their wrap-up
of the past eleven years of films with
the release of spider-man bar from home
I thought I'd go back and look over the
previous movies and discuss the most
hard-hitting lines from the franchise
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down the moments that impacted me the
most and why there was so powerful now
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you aren't fully up-to-date with the
films then I highly suggest that you
turn off now as there may be some things
that are room for you here if you're
still here just want to give a huge
thank you for clicking this video now
let's get into my breakdown of the top
10 most powerful lines in the MCU number
10 I'm with you till the end of the line
Captain America and Bucky --zz
friendship has lasted over 100 years and
the story of their Brotherhood has been
a strong facet of all the movies that
center around the characters the phrase
I'm witty till the end of the line
really sums up that through good and bad
thick and thin cap and Bucky will always
in some form or another be tied together
Captain America utters this - Bucky at
the end of Winter Soldier which recounts
a prior conversation that they had in
which the promise was also made and it's
pretty much the thing that brings Bucky
back from the brink it cements why cap
does the things that he does in civil
war and in as sure a sentence as
possible sums up the loyalty that the
character possesses for his friend
Captain America was originally a manner
of time that awoke in the future to find
that he'd lost everything
however Bucky - survived and the fact
that those two are still with one
another come the end of Avengers endgame
shows that it was a promise that didn't
end up being broken cementing it as the
tenth most powerful line for me number
nine I'm here to talk about the Avengers
initiative back in 2008 the idea of
superheroes interacting with one another
was a distant dream that never seemed
like it would come to fruition
these were heroes that existed in their
own universes and though they may
reference one another say is how
Superman was brought up in Batman
robbing there was no way that the heroes
in superhero movies would ever actually
meet that was until the post credit
scene of Iron Man in which we saw Tony
stock discover none other than Nick Fury
played by samuel l.jackson in his home
this line alone would change the movie
industry not only opening the idea of
shared universes but also teasing what
was to come down the line for cinemas
grandest creation everyone who saw this
back at the time of its release went
wild and there was an air of electricity
throughout the theater that made us
audience members believe that comic
books could come to life in more ways
than ever before this line really
started it all and that's why it's one
of the most powerful quotes in the MCU
number 8 bury me in the ocean black
panther was a revolutionary comic book
film for several reasons not only did it
completely crush the box office and was
the first superhero centric film that
was nominated for Best Picture it also
celebrated an African aesthetic and
introduced several black role models
that up until this point had been pretty
vacant in Hollywood the film's villain
quel manga was a big reason for the
movie's success and his journey
throughout the film was spellbinding a
complete outcast he managed to climb the
staircase of stay s until he became the
king of Wakanda kill [ __ ] was a man
with a mission to free the rest of the
world and his people from servitude this
entire quest is cemented in his final
few words in which he utters the
following just before death bury me in
the ocean with my ancestors that jump
from the ships because they knew death
was better than bondage this haunting
line will stay with you long after the
film's credits roll and it's showcases
why kill monger chose death rather than
dishonour at the end of the movie it
perfectly encapsulates his entire way of
thinking and shows why in the end he did
everything his own way number seven I
don't feel so good mr. stalk watching
half of our favorite heroes get wiped
out in the wake of the snap carried out
by Thanos was probably the most
heartbreaking moment in the entire
Marvel Universe not only did the villain
win but we also lost so many
up-and-coming characters that the final
few scenes of infinity war felt like the
lowest point in the Marvel Universe
still oh these weren't the main names
and it looked like the
could perhaps carry on all until
spider-man said the words I don't feel
so good now at this point the line has
become a meme used in all manner of
things including the recent Sony Disney
deal however at the time this was a
shocking scene that showed Marvel were
holding no punches when it came to
killing off their characters watching
Iron Man witnessed the death of a boy
that looked up to him was
soul-destroying and it was really I just
got I can't even do it this was the
lowest point of the entire MCU number 6
I know what it's like to lose
Thanos may have been teased throughout
the MCU before getting a film where he
was the main focus and his entrance
didn't disappoint in his opening
monologue the character says I know what
it's like to lose to feel so desperately
that you're right yet to fail
nonetheless as Lightning turns the legs
to jelly I ask you to what ends dredit
run from it destiny arrives all the same
and now it's here or should I say I am
this perfectly summed up just how
unbeatable the character was and how in
his words he is inevitable we pretty
much see throughout the film vision
tries to flee from his eventual fate
even forcing his love to kill him but
destiny still arrives and Thanos
collects all the stones throughout
infinity war he's an unstoppable force
besting the Avengers easily even though
they feel like they're right watching
them fail nonetheless pretty much
harkens back to his original statement
and from the opening of the film Danis
let's the audience and characters know
exactly how it's going to go it's the
perfect way to introduce them and it
helps to push his betrayal above most
making for an outstanding entrance
number 5 I had a date the ending of
Captain America is one that really pulls
at your heartstrings and is something
that we wouldn't see get closure until
10 years later when cap finally got
reunited with his long-lost loved Peggy
Carter at the end of his first film
Captain America finds that his sacrifice
has been a costly one and that he has
been catapulted into the future where
he's pretty much alone and isolated this
line perfectly sums up his
disappointment over how its action has
pretty much cost him his happiness and
it also showcase
is that he's coming to grips with the
fact that he's lost everything it's a
really powerful moment that I remember
left me feeling downtrodden upon leaving
the cinema I felt like cat would never
be able to love again and the fact that
we also had no idea where the Peggy was
alive or not made this really hit home
while so we can look back on this in
hindsight knowing that Steve did get to
be with the love of his life it's still
a brutal reminder of the cost of being
hero number four perfectly balanced as
all things should be
thanassis quest is arguably the most
eventful in the entire Marvel Universe
and his mission to balance the galaxy is
almost an analysis of yin and yang
everything needs balance good and bad
light and dark and in Thanos his mind he
is just correcting the galaxy and
putting it back on the right track after
he believes that overpopulation has
ruined it his way of thinking can be
encapsulated perfectly in this quote and
it shows that he truly believes that
everything should be in equal proportion
so as to not have chaos consume it with
the overpopulation debate currently
going on on our planet many often bring
up dan else's ideas and we've seen them
popularized in the hash tag Thanos was
right it's clear that some people are on
his side and those who are always
dropped this quote which shows that it's
a line that's transcended the film and
is now part of the zeitgeist number
three I can do this all day
similar to the quote we mentioned
earlier Captain America is a person
that's in it till the end of the line
the man is a symbol unshakable in his
beliefs that refuses to back down or
compromise no matter how dire
circumstances may seem the first time we
heard this line was when the character
was going up against a bully twice his
size and it's pretty much been a staple
of his vocabulary since its uttered
every time he goes head-to-head with
something or someone that seems
unstoppable Captain America is someone
that will fight at the end and not back
down in the face of adversity and this
is a catchphrase that boy extends the
trappings of mere dialogue it's
something that showcases just how
unshakable the character is and how even
till the end Captain America will still
get back up on his feet and go
head-to-head with any problem they may
come across it's a brilliant line and
what I say all the time and that's why
it secures the number three spot
number two Avengers Assemble Avengers
Assemble being said on screen by Captain
America was a theater erupting moment
after being teased throughout the
entirety of the MCU even to the point
that the camera cut before cap said it
in age of Ultron meant that when he
finally did it was huge on the screen we
finally saw all of the MCU characters at
the same time getting together as one to
save the universe and at the head of
this force was the man out of time
Captain America watching him rally the
troops together and finally say the
words fell a long time coming
but it was so worth seeing in this
setting that it felt like if it hadn't
been said before that it would have
under-delivered
this was an amazing setup - was arguably
the best action scene in the entire
franchise and it hammered home literally
cause of Manya just how worthy Captain
America was are leading the Avengers
into this final bow honorable mention
bring meat a nose yeah when Thor comes
down or what kinda everyone kind of
loses it a bit and starts smashing stuff
up and yeah this is just an amazing
moment I also want to give an honorable
mention - I Love You 3000 as this was an
incredible exchange between Tony Stark
and his daughter that left the end of
Avengers endgame without a dry eye in
the house it was heartbreaking seeing
this set in his final monologue but we
know that he did it because of his love
for his daughter and the love that he
had for everyone that he would be saving
unfortunately both of those entries just
missed out in the list because of our
number one and number one I am Iron Man
a number one entry is the infamous
phrase I am Iron Man
ever since Robert Downey jr. said at the
end of the first film back in 2008 it's
been pretty much angry in the entire MCU
before their secret identities had been
a huge part of superhero movies that
pretty much always remained intact
however this phrase threw caution to the
wind and showed that Marvel were playing
by different rules it massively changed
the scope of how comic-book movies would
be going forward and it pretty much
created the aesthetic that those with
superpowers could have their identities
exposed without it being the end of the
world this line carried through to Iron
Man 3 and was the ultimate slap in the
face
das in Avengers endgame when the villain
thought that he'd succeeded with his
plan Danis had been arrogant up until
this point believing that he was
inevitable however there's one person
who had an even bigger ego than he did
and that was Iron Man in this moment
when the character said the phrase for
the last time we knew that our hero had
finally saved us all and even at the
cost of his life everything was going to
be okay I am Iron Man is a line that
will stand strong in the MC forever and
is a quote that was there from the start
all the way until the end it's the
perfect way to close our list and that's
why it sits at number one obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the list
and if there's any lines that you think
should have made the top spot comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my fan theory that
the Eternals will show how nowhere came
to be I go over everything you need to
know about the Celestials and the
upcoming movies so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books and you
can follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and is the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this also just want to let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of John
wick 3 on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on your favorite quote in the
MCU in the comment section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then to ever get
surprised so best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you